you know this whole era of music
everyone raps over their track they just
rap over there somebody does yeah yeah
and i think they're like it's been like
that for a minute no it has been certain
certain aspects but it also hasn't been
but you got people like met the man no
but it's certain performances you don't
do that on right right and that's the
verse and that's the verses yeah in the
garden in the garden yeah and he's
ad-libbing calling it out yeah like he's
he kind of it's kind of like he
knew they was going to try
right and said i'm going to expose this
yeah but that's not what happened
it's not just not summer jams they're
all artists from everywhere to be fair
yeah you show me so i feel like today
i feel like they thought like if there's
a big venue right like for all this
protocol and i want people to understand
this right that they feel like ah you
know we just going to track it you know
what i'm saying it's the big venue i
want people to hear the the lyrics i
want everybody to hear the song but um
i think
the locks strategically made it like i
just
they know that protocol be like the two
track so going to do it like this so
people could hear us and we and it's
better for our audibles it was calling
what they i feel like portables really
made it like the that was one of their
angles yeah that's definitely
kind of like i think it was like
preparing like preparation right
i think like at the end of the day we
know lox
jada chic styles they're all together
always anyway
they they ain't like they're like just
kicking it when they gotta do chemistry
they're familiar you know what i mean
it was a chemistry party all three of
them was on like sheik was on his [ __ ]
yeah
still style's still going crazy yeah for
sure man back to what my brother jail
said he said listen he said he wished
they would have played certain records
just like i wish the order boot would
have been called when um like when they
played the um their verse from um big
pun um you know the back yeah you know
[ __ ] in the world you know daryl and
they're not yeah
being from tv joint mm-hmm norway we
wish that kim um verse would have came
like oh that's what y'all want to do let
me do mine all right let me let me cause
i feel his first it wasn't pretty
his first i think it was him
they didn't know each other's list so
yeah i was surprised that that's that's
what i'm saying the older boots like if
if he had to use he would have to text
him that would have been the moment if
you've been like you know guys i got a
verse on that song too
i think they had that like you said
strategically they had that plan they
were like ah they're gonna play this if
they play this that's when you play this